cette oeuvre d'art d'inspiration
tibétaine symbolise la spiritualité la
paix et l'amour
réalisé par trois moines venus
spécialement du sud de l'inde
ce mandat-là aspire à la paix dans le
monde il aura fallu à ces moines de
longues années d'enseignement pour
maîtriser cet art et connaître toutes
ces signification car sur cette fresque
chaque détail est porteur de sens il
commence par verser du sable du centre
vers l'extérieur
il verse le sable avec des petits corner
qu'il frotte pour faire tomber très peu
de sable très très lentement et les
grains de sable ont des tailles
différentes pour lorsque les dessins
doivent être plus fin c'est un sable
beaucoup plus fin le sable et coloré
donc ça permet ensuite de dessiner
finalement de faire une fresque colorée
avec notamment quatre côtés qui sont
bien déterminés jaune blanc ou rouge
vert et l'ensemble de cette
représentation à une symétrie centrale
et
comment dire ils ont appris par coeur
pendant des années tout tout la
description et donc ils connaissent par
coeur plusieurs mandats là ce mandat là
est dédié à taraz la mère de tous les
bouddhas cette divinité apporte la paix
le bonheur et élimine les souffrances
je suis
donc on s'est associé à la culture
tibétaine bouddhisme en particulier et
le sens même la nature rôle du bas salat
ces deux élus mais que ce type de
séquence de d'offrir le bonheur est dans
le
pour les moines bouddhistes cette oeuvre
symbolise le partage les réunionnais
pourront donc découvrir cette
réalisation jusqu'au 28 août au case de
la saline les bains le message majeurs
c'est à dire que c'est la paix en raid
comment établir la paix c'est on a tous
des difficultés relationnelles
personnels de santé ça en comme vous
êtes aussi témoin on est d'une fois
qu'on a ce corps on est sujet à toutes
ces difficultés mais il ya des façons de
réagir pour rétablir la paix la
meilleure façon de réagir c'est ne pas
se mettre en colère après les eaux votre
après soi même accepté être tranquille
et trouver les moyens pour résoudre dans
la paix et ça c'est le rétablissement de
la paix dans le monde
le mandala par essence est une oeuvre
éphémère elle sera détruite et
dispersées en mer afin de symboliser
l'impermanence et le caractère relatif
et transitoire de l'existence
cette année particulièrement le mandala
est placée sous le signe de la paix vu
les événements qui se sont passés donc
en europe et notamment en france dans
notre pays toutes ces grandes
souffrances qu'ont connues donc non des
individus les enfants des hommes des
femmes et c'est vrai que ce mandat là
peut apporter beaucoup de sérénité de
paix et de méditation à tous ceux qui
viennent visiter donc ce mandat là sur
le site de la saline les bains à saint
paul